Você sabia que pode estar ingerindo
plástico agora mesmo e sem perceber?
Pois é. E o pior, isso pode estar
afetando, ó, o seu cérebro. Uma revisão
científica publicada agora em novembro
de 2025 mostrou que microplásticos
conseguem atravessar a barreira que
protege nosso cérebro e podem agravar
doenças como Alzheimer e Parxon. Olha
só, garrafas plásticas, embalagens de
alimentos, tábuas de corte, até a poeira
de roupas sintéticas liberam essas
partículas microscópicas que a gente
acaba engolindo ou respirando todo dia.
E veja bem, os pesquisadores
identificaram cinco caminhos pelos quais
esses microplásticos causam problema.
Eles inflamam o cérebro, geram estresse
oxidativo nas células, danificam as
mitocôndrias, que são as usinas de
energia dos neurônios, rompem a barreira
protetora do cérebro e ainda podem
agredir diretamente os neurônios. No
Alzheimer, isso acelera o acúmulo
daquelas placas de betamide no Paxon,
prejudica os neurônios que produzem
dopamina. Então fica a dica prática.
Troque recipientes plásticos por vidro,
evite ultraprocessados e prefira roupas
de fibras naturais. pequenas mudanças
que podem proteger o seu cérebro a longo
prazo.